let's hop straight into this because
over the course of the years i've done a
lot of coaching calls with the guys
and i've got a call book next week with
a guy that's
very high profile makes over a quarter
million dollars a year very successful
in his field
but he's very very badly tied up
on a single mom that uh basically
abandoned him left him he's got one item
for it so let's hop into the five things
now before we go into it i want to say
this yes i know there's some ladies out
there they're going to be like
not all women are like that there's
unicorns out there congratulations
your unicorn ribbon is in the mail it's
coming your way
uh but on a balance of probabilities
these are the five most important things
guys that you really really need to be a
hell of a lot more attentive to
so you don't wind up in a situation
where you can't function or you
have some issues getting over a lost one
usually the single mom
number one cuckoldry now
if you're not familiar with what
cuckoldry is this is probably one of the
biggest factors that most smart guys
when they're navigating the sexual
marketplace will pass
on single moms because usually the
biggest reward when it comes to children
is
the fact that they carry your dna and
your last name
uh it's such an important thing that
when you get into
um hollywood pieces or media pieces that
involve royalty or anything that's regal
you know for example let's take game of
thrones as a recent example
you know you heard throughout the entire
series well he's not a stark
you know and that's what the consistency
is when it comes to cuckoldry is
yeah it is important but it's so
important to
men as fathers that they know that their
name is passed on
right they know that their name carries
meaning and that name with its dna is
passed on
and when you get involved with a single
mom and you start to raise her kids
you're basically raising another man's
children you're a cuck
there's animals in the wild that'll
basically drop their eggs in the nest of
other birds
birds you know more specifically and
those
dumb birds will raise the eggs that are
hatched as their own they don't
they don't pay attention to the details
and that's really what guys get
themselves into when they get wound up
with single moms is they end up getting
cuckolded where they end up essentially
applying their
tools resources and everything to the
genetic investment of another
man it's it's not particularly rewarding
it's often used as a disparaging term on
the internet these days
it's usually the number one reasons why
most most guys pass on
you